[Music]
omnipotent dictators whether it's Putin
or Xi Jinping are never quite as
powerful as they think they are how did
the left become warmongers in the course
of four decades when they'd previously
been the opposite I think we've been
adjusting both intellectually and
politically to a a a relative decline in
our power for 30 or 40 years because
another thing that we're seeing coming
out of the war in Ukraine is in fact a
massive risk to world food security
[Music]
because I wonder whether we should also
be thinking about moral power or the
lack of it and whether the U.S lost the
moral High Ground when it invaded Iraq
and made a lot of other countries in the
world think well why should America have
hegar money over anymore Fiona yeah
right Marianne that that is
um a thread that we're seeing coming to
the foreign is probably you know at the
Crux of this sort of explanation about
why there is a pushback now against a
hegemon you're really seeing you know
what we would call the rise of the rest
against the us as a factor of war in
Ukraine I mean a little earlier in one
of the other sessions I mentioned that
there's you know an awful lot of people
who believe that the origins of the war
in Ukraine are actually in actions by
the United States uh you know completely
discounting you know Russia's own agency
in this and you know Vladimir Putin's
because there is that belief well the
United States set the tone by inverting
Iraq in 2003 you know two wrongs don't
make a right but you know this was in a
series of crimes there's been you know
no
um consequences from this you know
George W bush is sitting painting now
he's not you know sitting in the
international criminal court in the head
but I've heard this you know being said
to me you know by leaders of other
countries you know so why is this
different well you know there is
um a lot to be said for uh you know what
happened in 2003 but that obviously
doesn't justify in any way uh Russia's
decision and Putin's decision to invade
Ukraine but it's bringing that kind of
uh discourse out to the force so as
you're saying there is a link between
what happened in Iraq in 2003 in many
people's minds and you know what is
happening now but as as Malcolm said you
know the relative decline of the United
States in very relative terms I mean
really maybe we shouldn't call it a
decline it's all because in economic and
military power the United States hasn't
really declined at all but moral
Authority is clearly a waning attribute
an asset for the United States in the
current environment another thing that
we're seeing coming out of the war in
Ukraine is in fact a massive risk to
world food security I mean all of us now
know that Ukraine was responsible 20 of
world grain production and in fact as a
result of what's happening in the war
now and the impingement on the ability
of Ukraine uh to produce the kind of
copy as it has in the past between 10
and 20 million people are likely to die
this year and they're not also they're
not going to be here in the United
Kingdom or the United States but they
are going to be in Africa and in the
Middle East
and whatever we do and as samalakam is
saying in terms of kind of thinking
about Ukraine's future has to set a
precedent for changing things moving
forward it can't be a resolution that
leaves uh India vulnerable in the
Himalayas or elsewhere to predation from
a larger power of uh of China across the
way it has to be a way in which we're
kind of thinking about the future set of
interactions thinking in new ways about
how we're going to ensure uh food
security as well I just sort of fear
many times that we're having our
conversations in the sort of the older
patterns and not recognizing the world
is changing around underneath us which
is why so many countries in the world
are saying we don't want a hegemon we
don't want to go back to what we had in
World War one and World War II we want
to see development tackle we want to see
climate change I mean it's not just
tivolu that's going to you know
disappear in uh 10 years and I commend
all of you to look there's a video
online now about the people of Tivoli
there's only 11 000 of them but still
they're going to lose their country and
they're going to have to be out there
looking for somewhere else and they're
saying Millions more people are within
the next five 10 15 years going to be in
the same situation how are we going to
contend with it
so farcical for us to be fighting over
borders and and the the kind of ships of
terrorism is thinking that's going to
drive things forward because the world
even just the Topography is going to be
changing as well so I think we've got to
find ways of talking about that and
addressing it
now when I look at the balance of forces
as they are sometimes described at the
moment
the person who puzzles me a great deal
Putin doesn't puzzle me he's a thug the
person who puzzles me is Xi Jinping
because Xi Jinping is a very very bright
guy and he we all know what his single
most strategic objective is it's to
occupy Taiwan and incorporate it into
China
now you would have thought that if that
was his strategic objective and if he
was a good Diplomat or able to listen to
his diplomats the last thing you do
while you're threatening Taiwan is to
antagonize not the forget America forget
Europe to antagonize all your Asian
Neighbors
simultaneously
so he is at the very one same moment he
has territorial claims against Japan for
certain Islands south of Japan similar
claims against South Korea he's
threatening Taiwan in the South China
Sea he's upset six Southeast Asian
countries by militarizing tiny little
islets and trying to turn it into a
Chinese controlled sea and then I come
to India and India for a long time has
had a border dispute with China and last
year I think it was last year the year
before there was a border infringing by
China and 30 Indian soldiers were killed
and such was the outrage in India that
India changed not just its foreign
policy of three years but of 60 years
because throughout the Cold War India
had never taken sides between the Soviet
Union and the West simply said
that this is not our conflict
Moody hoped to do that with China
something similar and the Chinese are Xi
Jinping because he's the guy who takes
the decisions we're so convinced of
their own omnipotence
that they have infringed their
relationship so what has happened India
and Japan are now having joint Naval
exercises what do India and Japan have
in common other than they both share a
Chinese border
Vietnam you all know the history of
Vietnam and America Vietnam has said the
government have said publicly today
America is our partner China is the
country where
worried about and Japan which since 1945
hasn't even had an army it calls itself
a self-defense Force it's had the most
pacifist foreign policy for years
Japanese ministers publicly said in the
last couple of months that if Taiwan was
to be invaded by China Japan would see
that as a threat to its own National
Security and India of course has joined
with the Japan United States and
Australia on what is called the quad not
it's not a military organization it
might One Day become one but it's
certainly not now but it's trying to
plan how to deal with China so the final
point I make and it's a very short point
is that
omnipotent dictators whether it's Putin
or Xi Jinping are never quite as
powerful as they think they are we saw
that in China just a few months ago when
Xi Jinping who had insisted on a zero
covert campaign for several years and
was intending to continue it there were
riots all over China and within three
weeks he bent the knee and said guess
what we've decided we don't have to have
a covered zero policy after all
no that was interesting to watch but
two billion 1.3 billion Chinese all saw
their own dictator having to bend the
knee to public opinion on that issue and
if he's done it once he may one day have
to do it again
this is the first attempt when you say
who's the Wii I mean the Wii is the G7
countries and that's you know we're 10
15 of the world's population but 40 odd
45 of the world's GDP so the G7 are
still a powerful group they're not the
dominant group but they're a very
powerful group that's the we and the the
Chinese are very interested in this
because this is the first time G7
countries have attempted a big sanctions
policy against a big and important
country like Russia really important and
China is watching this very very
carefully because they have been
impressed as we have impressed ourselves
at the degree of political consensus
within the G7 we didn't we didn't think
that there would be this much consensus
whether it lasted or not I don't know
and I worry that it won't but we are
here at the moment and the consensus is
still pretty strong and so China is
extremely interested in a the effective
sanction this may play to Simon's point
but a the effective sanctions on Russia
over the long term
but what should our response be well in
the light of our X experience with
sanctions with Russia does that mean
that we have to engage in military Moves
In in relation to Taiwan or do we think
there is a diplomatic move what what is
what should the consequences be of the
lesson for us
on the sanctions Point insofar as they
they are consensual and they're and they
are quite powerful
um in terms of that that is true we
ought to be making it clear to China and
I think you know they're watching for
themselves that G7 sanctions policies
are actually
um quite strong
the event of a Taiwan invasion you know
there would be yeah it will likely to be
similar sanctions I mean remember that
the Chinese at the moment are really
frightened of secondary sanctions
Russia is because they worry that we'll
chase them for secondary sanctions and
really do economic harm that's the power
of the G7 so do you think there is
nothing to learn from the way that
sanctions have worked with Russia and
that we can apply sanctions to China in
a in a selective way which will be
effective at containing the Taiwan
situation I don't know if I don't know
if we can do it again or we should do it
again but what is what is to be learned
is that this degree of consensus is
quite impressive and it impresses us for
the moment it may or may not be
impressing the Chinese leadership and
we'll see in due course whether that's
you know whether they take any notice of
that I think we've been adjusting both
intellectually and politically to uh a a
a a relative decline in our power for 30
or 40 years but that doesn't mean to say
that we can't we don't have interest we
want to try to defend but wasn't that
one of the reasons why there was so much
commentary uh about Putin which he's
obviously crazy remember all of that
stuff about he's mentally unstable
um all of it wasn't in fact the story
that from uh Putin's point of view once
he had as it were inverted commas
alliance with China there was an
alternative notion another world order
in which
the economies of China India so forth
and and and and Russia could provide an
alternative basis for the west and
instead of our thinking oh they've just
got to go along with us they thought no
we're going to build our own world and
what's more does every sign that that
world is the world we are going to be
living in in the next 25 years there are
four big powers in the world the big
four is America China India Russia and
they're big for different reasons two of
those four China and Russia are
explicitly revisionist which is to say
they want to change the rules of the
world system that they inherited after
the second world war so two out of four
revisionists during the Trump
Administration three out of four were
revisionists and in some respects with
Modi four out of four might be
revisionist so we are in a period of
transition and that two out of four
being revisionist is not going to change
in the coming era and that's the
situation we're in we're in appeared a
great transition so it's not it's not
characterized in a sort of cartoony way
of a bunch of arrogant Western
politicians everybody's trying to adjust
to this new transition but we do have
interest to try to defend
[Music]
my view about Freedom under the law
having traveled and lived in countries
where it doesn't exist is that it is
something we should be much more
concerned about defending in our own
circumstances than in trying to impose
on other people uh what astonishes me
about the the past 30 or 40 years in
this country and indeed the United
States and perhaps in some European
countries as well is what has happened
to the left
the left when I was growing up and when
I was part of it was deeply opposed to
the habit of of invading other countries
and demanding that they should follow
our rules and do as we told them since
the uh particularly the Kosovo War which
was a dress rehearsal for the Iraq War
and much of the Yugoslav intervention
the countries of the democratic West and
the and the left within them have become
very very enthusiastic about imposing
what we believe to be our way of life by
force on others and I don't understand
I've tried and tried to work out exactly
what's motivated this but it seems to me
to be a very strange thing which
somebody if I ever do write another book
perhaps it's what I shall write about
how did the left become warmongers in
the course of four decades when they'd
previously been the opposite but they
are now and whatever whenever I look
around for a warmonger it's someone on
the left I'll find doing it the guardian
for goodness sake which in the 60s was
supposed to practically any war that
existed and some that didn't is now for
any war that comes along how did this
happen why do we think like this what we
actually need to be concerned about is
we are not particularly rich or
particularly powerful and after a few
more weeks of less trust we'd be a lot
less rich and a lot less powerful
foreign policies and extension of
domestic policy what is it that you want
foreign policy to do fundamentally it's
to keep you safe from danger it's not a
go messing around in other people's
countries telling them what to do and
how to behave
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV